outer bank stars madeleine klein and
chase stokes have broken up according to
multiple reports the actors called it
quits after more than a year of dating
so welcome to the poke life
is it everything you've ever dreamed of
and more
oh yeah oh madeline and chase met while
filming the first season of the hit
netflix series in 2020 and while
chatting with e.t before the show's
release the two played coy about their
on-screen romance bleeding into their
off-camera lives
right now
we are kind of enjoying our time
nothing nothing exclusive but two months
later madeline and chase finally went
instagram official chase shared photos
on the beach together with the caption
cats out of the bag while madeline
posted the same pics adding i've fallen
and i can't get up later that year the
actress opened up to it about being in
love
love is tight
and
it's cool too
it's cool to share this experience with
your favorite people
and also
your favorite person
and
yeah i don't i don't really know
i feel very happy fast forward to 2021
madeline and chase's relationship became
more serious they even celebrated their
one year anniversary in april and while
speaking about their outer banks
characters john b and sarah getting
married in season two
by the power vested in me
by the sky
the stars
and the sea
the duo revealed their own thoughts on
marriage do you guys in your real lives
talk about marriage or do you just leave
that to the john b and sarah of it all
um i definitely think 16. well look
everybody has their own experience right
like it works for some people i mean
we've seen couples who got married at 16
who are now in their 80s and you know
sure 90s who are still together and yeah
wildly in love so i don't think that the
age should specifically define it i
think love is something that
should move that needle
now it's unknown what their split means
for season three of outer banks but when
speaking about the next season in june
they had this to say to e.t i think that
they deserve all of the
relaxing time after you know everything
that they've gone through it was
interesting i mean like they they made
the comment and then
you're kind of like
oh wow that just kind of flew over a lot
of people's hats but
um
i think that's the john beans fair way a
little bit yeah
i think
i feel like it'd be really fun in season
three
you know if we're if we get one to see
them actually start to like truly get to
know each other like in a very real
sense like
they're married but they actually kind
of don't know a whole lot about each i
feel like that would be really fun